شهرًا للحصول على لقاح covane covid بسرعة مذهلة
لالتقاط الأنفاس ، لماذا عادةً ما يستغرق
عدة سنوات ،
فلماذا كان أسرع هذه المرة
علماء العلوم الذين ابتكروا نوعًا من
الأبحاث التي لا يمكنني حتى
شرحها لك ولكنها مهدت الطريق
لفايزر وماديرنا  اللقاحات الآن أحد
الأشخاص
الذين لا يمكنك استبعادهم من هذه
المحادثة
هو كل ما نحتاجه لعقد
هذه الليلة عزيزي
الدكتورة كيت كوريكو تنضم إلي
الآن وقصة النجاح الأمريكي
إذا وُلِدَت هنغاريا إلى هنا بدون
أي شيء يائسًا من أجل أفضل  أصبحت الحياة وتعليم
كل شيء صعبًا بسبب
المكان الذي أتت منه وكونها
امرأة في
مجال صعب للغاية على المرأة ، كان عليها أن تترك
عائلتها للعمل طوال الوقت
لكنها أجرت
بحثًا لم يكن أحد يعتقد أنه
ممكن.  أنت لكونك معنا
دكتور ، أشكرك على جعل الأمل
ممكنًا
في بلدنا الليلة ، شكرًا لك على سلامتي ،
لذلك عندما سمعت
أن التجربة كانت ناجحة مع شركة
Pfizer
و Moderna i  قرأت أنك لم تكن
متفاجئًا حقًا من
أن اللقاحات أثبتت فعاليتها
حتى بعد هذا الوقت القصير ،
لماذا ما كنت تعلم أنه كان علينا أن
نتعلمه؟
توقعت أنه سيعمل لأن لدينا
بالفعل
تجربة كافية واه كنت
واثقًا من أنها ستنجح  وأنا سعيد
جدًا لأنها نجحت حقًا ، لقد سمعت أنك
احتفلت بكيس كامل
من الفول السوداني المغطى بالشوكولاتة ، نعم ، كان
جروبر ، نعم هذا هو المفضل لدي ،
لكنك تعلم أنني لست نوعًا من
الأشخاص المتحمسين الذين
نعم هذا لطيف
جيدًا أعتقد أن هذا هو بالضبط  ما
يجب أن يكون عليه العالم هو أنك تدور
حول الإنجاز التالي
وتكتشفه وأنك لست متفاجئًا بما
أظهرته بالفعل الآن
يحتاج الناس إلى معرفة أن هذا لم يحدث تقريبًا إلى أي
مدى كان عليك  جاهد من أجل هذا
النوع من
منهجية أه من العلم واستخدام rna
أه لتستخدم بهذه الطريقة مدى صعوبة
القتال
كان صعبًا لأن الناس
لم يصدقوا أن أه
الرسول rna يمكن أن يكون علاجًا
ومعه  رسم زميلي وايزمان
في جامعة بنسلفانيا طورنا
هذه الطريقة حيث قمنا بتغيير
مكون واحد في rna
مما جعله أقل مناعة ومن
الممكن استخدامه لنوع مختلف من
العلاج
واتضح أيضًا
أنه الأفضل لـ  لقاح
وهكذا استغرق الأمر بعض الوقت
حتى يكتشف الناس اكتشافنا
ثم بالطبع في النهاية الآن ونحن
متحمسون جدًا
لأنه أصبح لقاحًا جزءًا من هذا اللقاح
لكلا الشركتين
وسنحتفل حقًا عندما أه
تعرف هذا أه
الإنسان  تنتهي المعاناة عندما
تعرف المشقة
وينتهي كل هذا الوقت الرهيب
ونأمل في الصيف عندما ننسى
الفيروس واللقاح ، ثم
سأحتفل حقًا بمدى ثقتك في
أن اللقاح سيحدث فرقًا كبيرًا
أنا واثق جدًا من أنني
سأحصل على اللقاح يوم
الخميس في جامعة
بنسلفانيا مع درو
وايزمان لأننا نحصل معًا على اللقاح
أن
بعض اكتشافاتنا قد تم دمجها فيها
وأنه تاريخي ومهم للغاية
بالنسبة لنا أن نحصل على اللقاح